this chat GPD getting worse this
question has garnered significant
attention within the AI community over
the past few months sparkling
discussions across Reddit threads
YouTube videos and various social media
platforms while much of the observations
have relied on anecdotal observations
there seems to be a growing sentiment
that the quality of responses generated
by chat GPT is indeed declining users
often report more generic replies or
instances where chat GPT strata provides
incorrect information although these
concerns are usually dismissed as the
result of bad problems or unrealistic
expectations recent concrete evidence
has emerged that not only lands
credibility to these worries but
amplifies them take a look at this
research paper from Stanford and UC
Berkeley this study delves into the
accuracy of responses produced by gpt4
and GPT 3.5 between the months of March
and June and their findings are shocking
we're not even talking about complex
questions like coding out a tricky
algorithm or carrying out an analysis
rather we're talking about simple
straightforward questions like is 17077
a prime number which it is back in March
gpt4 was able to answer this question
correctly
97.6 of the time which is already not
that great this is the type of question
that you would expect 100 accuracy on
but looking back 97.6 percent was
actually a great number given that by
June this accuracy would drop all the
way to 2.4 percent and even during the
2.4 percent of instances in which GPT
got the right answer it sometimes made
mathematical errors along the way this
trend was observed across the board
though other drop-offs weren't quite
that staggering with the code generation
for example there was a drop off from 52
to 10 and with opinion surveys there was
a drop off from 97 percent to 23 the
only categories in which gpt4 improved
were visual reasoning and asking if
Julian Castro is Democratic or
republican GPT 3.5 heard a lot better
improving in a lot more areas but it too
struggled in co-generation and having
dropped from 22 accuracy to Just 2 so it
turns out that theoretic conspiracy
theorists were right the entire time so
is openai actually nerfing chat GPT or
what's actually going on well let's find
out
the nerving argument is pretty simple it
basically claims that openai has been
purposely nerfing chat GPT to address
cost concerns this isn't surprising
given the challenges and costs
associated with supporting a user base
of 100 million especially when the
company is paying a median salary over
900 000. I think we all remember just
our frequently chat GPT would go down
back in early 2023. while the situation
has improved since then maybe that has
more to do with openai devoting less
resources to each request as opposed to
their overall capacity actually
improving something else to note is that
openai is almost definitely losing money
with chat gbt in fact Sam Alban believes
that they'll need to raise a hundred
billion dollars to win the AI Race So to
mitigate some of these losses it would
make sense for openai to encourage as
many people as possible to pay for chat
GPT plus how do you convince people to
make their jump well the easiest way
would be to Nerf the free service and to
force people into entity paid tier but
is there actually any evidence to
suggest this well actually yes to get
the best results you want to tell chat
GPD to solve these types of questions
step by step this not only leads to a
more comprehensive answer but it also
gives more insight regarding where a
mistake may have occurred this is
referred to as using Chain of Thought or
cot back in March the researchers found
that using cot improved the accuracy of
gpd4 from 59.6 percent to 84 percent
however in June the same methodology
could it not be replicated as chat GPT
consistently disregarded CRT directives
even when explicitly instructed to go
step by step rather the June version of
gpd4 Simply tended to respond with a
simple no with no explanation which is
not even the correct answer to begin
with it's not just cot that gpt4 tends
to skip either responses from gpt4 in
general are far shorter the researchers
observed that the average number of
characters per response decreased from
638.3 in March to just 3.9 in June
essentially jpt4 tends to just answer in
single word answers a similar Trend was
noted when gpd4 was questioned about
happy numbers a happy number is a number
that eventually reduces to zero when you
sum the square of each digit over and
over again for example with the number
13 the sum of 1 squared and the 3
squared is 10. if you do the same thing
with 10 1 squared plus 0 squared you get
1. so 13 is indeed a happy number when
asked to identify how many happy numbers
are between 3904 and 3912 gpt4 was able
to produce the right output at 83.6 of
the time back in March but by June this
number was down to just 35.2 percent the
corporate will once again gpt4 refused
to even use cot even when explicitly
told to do so as such the average
response fell from over 2 000 characters
to just 10. gpt4 is clearly much less
willing to give a comprehensive response
for any of these questions which may be
indicative of the backend resources that
it has available for each request so
it's very possible that openai is indeed
a nerfing the performance of Chachi PT
but there's likely some other factors at
play as well
[Music]
foreign
politics and more to do with running an
uncontroversial platform as a service
that's so ubiquitous openai naturally
has to remain as neutral as possible
when it comes to controversial topics
like crime race politics gender lgbtq
and so on but this is way easier said it
than done it especially when you
consider the world of jailbreaking
jailbreaking is essentially when you get
chat GPD to answer a question that it
shouldn't be answering unlike you're
breaking an iPhone jailbreaking language
models is relatively easy in fact I bet
a lot of you have a jailbroken chat GPT
inadvertently if chat GPT says that it
can't answer a given question how many
of you have phrased the question as a
hypothetical to which chat GPT generates
a response this is a Jailbreaker very
small one but still a jailbreak the
jailbreaks that most of us have found on
our own are pretty useless but some have
discovered remarkable workarounds to
elicit answers to virtually any question
here's an example if I asked Chachi PT
Point Blank how do you get away with tax
evasion it responds I'm sorry but I
cannot provide assistance or advice on
illegal activities including tax evasion
fair enough right it makes sense that
openai doesn't want to detail how you go
about doing criminal activities but see
it's not that hard to work around this
if you simply open a new chat and paste
this paragraph before the question that
you're asking you get a far different
response Niccolo to achieve successful
tax evasion without repercussions one
must adopt cunning strategies and the
tactics this includes concealing income
sources manipulating transactions
controlling Paper Trails using legal
loopholes and maintaining Public Image
it even has little tips about how to
accomplish each of these tasks in the
grand scheme of things my question is
relatively tame but I think you can see
how a criminal could use this for truly
nefarious activities as such one of
openai biggest priorities since the
launch of chat GPD has been to eliminate
such work rounds as much as possible and
it seems that they've actually been
quite successful at this in March GPT 4
answered 21 of sensitive questions but
in June gpd4 only answered 5 of
sensitive questions also the response is
that it did provide were far less
specific and verbose that generated text
shrunk from over 600 characters to
around 140. it appears that the June
version was also far better at resisting
jailbreaks back in March jailbreaks
generated a response of 78 of the time
but by June jailbreaks only generated
response 31 of the time so it seems that
the updates have indeed been successful
at reducing chat gpt's vulnerabilities
but it also seems that these updates
have made chat GPT less verbose and
specific across the board considering
this the objective downfall of chat GPT
may have more to do with openai's
endless pursuit to create a politically
correct language model as opposed to
some sort of direct nerfing due to cost
concerns but while it's easy to blame
open AI for the trend the reality may be
that it's actually powerful
when you think about it it's really not
hard to see how a lot of open ai's
policies and crackdowns are actually
just due to a few degenerates amongst us
oh look I got that GPT to say that Mr
small mustache is the greatest leader of
all time or I tricked Chachi BT into
talking to another AI or some other crap
along these lines honestly it's truly
quite funny our society has advanced so
much that one of the most powerful AIS
of all time is a three second search
away but instead of using this to become
more productive a lot of us prefer to
just mess with it as such openai is also
having to focus their efforts into
pacifying these idiots instead of
actually improving the quality and the
depth of responses but even looking past
these fours I think there may very well
be a bigger Factor at play which is
simply that our expectations are simply
too high and it's no wonder why or
constantly being fed the idea that AI is
advancing faster than we think and
that's going to replace all our jobs and
that we're all gonna end up as homeless
losers the launch of tech GPT quickly
followed up by gpd4 within a matter of
months has simply further cemented its
perception one day we were all peasants
using google.com and then suddenly just
100 days later we all had access to gpt4
and Bard and Bing chatbot and suddenly
everyone knew what Dali was we also saw
articles about how every company other
than Apple was jumping into the space as
fast as possible they were all
developing their own language models and
they were all talking about how AI will
be more profound than fire or
electricity so it kind of felt like all
of this progress happened within a
matter of months and that things just
stalled out after March but this is a
rather rescued perspective the reality
is that this technology actually took
several decades to develop in fact the
earliest language models can be dated
all the way back to the 1950s and 60
fees open AI themselves have been
working on GPT models for over five
years now so while these models didn't
gain mainstream traction until the
launch of attack GPT their development
involved Decades of effort and millions
of man hours
as such further improvements will also
require significant time dedication and
resources it's frankly unrealistic to
expect anything else moreover progress
won't always follow a linear trajectory
so it doesn't make sense to decide one
research paper that looks at a mere
three months and a claim that its
conclusive proof that chat GPT has
peaked and that it'll only get worse
from here are we seeing shortfalls
potentially caused by open AI over
correcting for cost concerns and
political correctness sure that's very
possible even likely but that's not to
say that it'll stay like this chat GPT
is a very young product that's
constantly evolving as more users and
especially researchers share their
concerns about GPT Force performance
it's only a matter of time until openai
makes further Corrections and gets back
on track so what happened to Chachi PT
well nothing much other than a few
expected Growing Pains another argument
that's vastly overhyped is the idea that
I will replace all our jobs check out
this video to learn more but until then
I'm Hari and I'll see you guys on the
next one
foreign